les accusés dans cette affaire
sont accusés de meurtres tortures
et autres atrocités commis au nom de la
science médicale l'un de ses médecins
jugés au procès de nuremberg s'appelle
wilhelm buybox accusé de crimes de
guerre et de crimes contre l'humanité en
lien avec des expériences médicales
c'est le principal protagoniste de la
reconstitution joué par des étudiants
des facultés de santé et de droit de
l'université versailles saint quentin un
travail de plusieurs mois tout ce texte
convient de lire et de représenter était
à l'origine en allemand et donc il ya
d'abord eu un travail de bas de
recherche de documentation de traduction
parce qu'on est à des milliers de pages
quinté réduit aussi ses suivis tout ce
qui était vraiment le travail théâtral
au fur et à mesure au fur et à mesure
pendant des répétitions donc maintenant
qu'on s'était bien approprié le sens de
tout essayer de bien retranscrire ça au
public dans le public l'ancien ministre
de la santé agnès buzyn pour elle la
question du consentement aux expériences
médicales est au coeur de ce procès un
questionnement à l'origine du code de
nuremberg véritable acte de naissance de
la bioéthique les questions d'éthique
reste au coeur de la relation médecin
malade la question du consentement
et ton toujours en état de donner un
consentement est il éclairé quel est
l'état de vulnérabilité des gens c'est
la grande question qui est posée ce
médecin bagel bagel buck et a été
responsable de ses actes même s'il ya eu
un ordre et donc tous nos étudiants qui
seront de futurs professionnels quelle
sera leur responsabilité en tant que
professionnel on souhaite donner à nos
étudiants jurés futurs juristes avocats
magistrats médecins infirmiers sages
femmes des clés pour comprendre le monde
contemporain à partir de l'histoire
boc
coupable de crimes de guerre et de
crimes contre une verte et finalement
wilhelm buybox sera condamné à 15 ans de
prison après cette reconstitution du
procès au sénat la soirée s'est
poursuivie avec un débat sur le
consentement aux soins
[Applaudissements]